で これで今日の偈なんですけど
だからこのミツバチのような生き方であると
ミツバチが花に入って
花の花粉と蜜を取って
誰が損するんです？そういう花はかわいそうに
花のものなくなったんですか？盗まれたんですか？逆でしょ
ミツバチが来たことで
花は自分の目的を達するんです
来なかったらただ単に枯れて実ることはできない
実るために咲いた花でしょ
誰も虫が来なかったら
それはもう蝶々でもミツバチでも誰も来なかったならばアウト
かわいそうに だからミツバチが花に行くような感じで
花には色も変えませんし
花びらが食わせることもないし
花が用意している蜜をもらって帰る
それでその花が自分が何のために現れたかっていう
その目的には達する そういう風な決まりで托鉢するんだよ
だから互いに得するんですね
お坊さんはそれで修行できる
何も心配することなく
最強の方々は人生を多大な幸福を恵み
恵みを受けたりする 人間というのは幸福で幸せで豊かでいたいいたい必死でしょうに
今世でも来世でももう無数に
その徳で幸せで生きていられる
ですから 両方ともそういうことで得するシステムにしたんです
そういう托鉢システムはお釈迦様以外誰も作っても何ともならない
托鉢文化はインドであったんですけど
ものすごい品のない泥棒行為なんですね
結局は 例えば客を神様やと思うこと自体がすごい立派な考え方ですよ
でもそれまた悪用されちゃう
自分の国でも客は神様よという考え方
神様っていう風にも言わないんですけど
その服は着るんですね
ヒンドゥー教じゃないんだから
客の接待することが最高な行為である
最高といってもすごい優れている行為であるということで
まあどんな人でも何かちょこっと困っているとわかったら
まあ必死であれこれとかなんでもやる
で それでまあこの我々の原始文化はもう壊されちゃって
西洋文化になってるんだから
まあなかなかね 知らない人だったら怖いとやべえと鍵をつけておこうという風に立派に成長してますけどね
それはもうこの原始人友達に偉大なるヨーロッパの文化を教えてあげなくちゃって教えてくれてるんだからね
だからまあ家に機関銃でも鉄砲でもないともう野蛮人ですね
客を追い出すために でも今も村だったらね
村にどこか知らない人が来ると
もうみんなあっちこっちから来るわ
いろいろ話聞くわ もう必要なものはあれこれで持ってくるわ
もうわいわいわいわいと喋るんですよ
もう 互いに あと先生 その点では
例えば他の遠いところに行ったでもね
途中で車が故障しちゃってもどうしようもなくなっても全然心配しない
もう修理できるところも何にもなくなっても
まあそこら辺のちょっと見える家どこか行けばいいんです
今日は大変でこういうこと
あ そうですか それはそれは大変ということで
ご飯作ってくれるわ 寝るところは何とか
貧しいんだけど みんなお互いに
もうどこかでマットでも敷いてね
もう寝ることはできるわ
そこでそういう人々はこれなんとか修理できる誰かいないでしょうかとかね
ああ あちらにいるんだから
私はもう行って連れてきますよと言って
自転車に乗って連れてくるわとかね
あるいはもうこれ押してあげた方がいいなと思ったら
もうどこかにところまで押してあげたりする
押してあげる距離が長いんだったら
もう牛車でも持ってきて
牛にでも頼んで押してあげましょうとやってくれますよ
それにお金いくらかった？それはなし
ただ人を助けてあげたことで
もうね 喜ぶ だから人間と喋る技を持ってないとこれできないんですよ
我々はもう一分で十分ですよ
随分ぺったし仲良くするためには
もう寝食入る何でも喋る
たった一分あれば だから
まあですから お互いに楽しい
一応助けてもらう側も結構楽しいし
みんなといろいろ喋ったりして
冗談言えばもう子供ならもうからかったりするわ
あれやること何のこともない
で それ終わったらみんなよし
帰るぞということで まあ今日はいいことできたぞというと
もうすごい一人勝手に喜んで帰ったりする
だから この客に対して
そういうことは一応自分の国でもあることはもう当然ありますけど
神という一言は使わない
しかし この托鉢する人からものをもらうということは
仏教はもうすごい嫌なことであると
ある時 お釈迦様ははっきり言うんですよ
この世の中で一番惨めなこと
人間として 一番惨めなことといえば
人から何かもらって食べるということ
だからそれだけは避けなさいという意味なんですよ
だから人間というのは何か自分で仕事をして食べなくちゃいけない
仕事も何もしないでもらうということは
もう最悪惨めだ だからそういう人になったならば
ものすごい不幸ですと
だからそういう人々にもできるだけ気付いてなさいということになるんです
それは人間としてはとんでもないことですと
あってはならない現象であると
例えば人がホームレスになったならば
これはもうあってはならない現象である
とにかくみんなでもうできる範囲で助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだ
いうことにもあって 人に頼って生活する羽目になったら
もうよっぽどそれが惨めな人間であるということにもする
だからそういうところはもうほとんどもう忘れかけてますよ
仏教のこの厳しさっていうのはね
だからこの仏教の人々はもうなかなか頑張らないところもあるしね
それはブッダの教えじゃないんです
ものすごいしっかりと頑張らなくちゃいけない
頑張る連中も頑張りますよ
もう朝も昼も夜も全然へっちゃらで
気にしないでね すごい頑張るんです
だからといって金儲かるぞというそこもそこまでもないんですね
ただ淡々と頑張る はい
そこまで文化的なことで
それから托鉢に対して教理というかね
教理学ですかね 宗教的なね
微妙な哲学的な意味もあります
この輪廻の生きる輪廻で生きるっていうこと自体がすごい残酷行為なんですよ
生きてて良かったんじゃなくて
もう生きて生まれて悪かったっていうところが仏教の言い方なんですよ
おめでたい話じゃないんですよ
生まれてすぐご出家様でしたと言った方がいいんですよ
それからどんな悪いことをするかも決まってないでしょうに
かわいそうに生まれてきたんだと
私は言わないんだけど
赤ちゃんにはそう思っちゃいますよ
結局は まあもう日本でも結構赤ちゃんを抱っこしてあげたりは
もう可愛いでしょうと
まあまあ可愛い可愛いですね
私も言いますけどね これからお前大変だよ
この世の中でね どうなるか分かったもんじゃないよ
こんな苦しい人生に耐えられるのかと
だからなんでこの野郎生まれてきやがったという
こんな大変な世界なのに
いいこと一つもないのにと
それ決してこのそれもその子をすごくもう慈しみで思っちゃいますよ
慈しみの上で 今は何も世間も知らない
知らず 誰とも笑っちゃうわ
もうもうちっちゃな指でもうじっと握りしめるはもう可愛いことは可愛いんですけど
でも だからもう大変なところに来たなと
君はと だからこの生まれるということはおめでたいじゃないんですよ
生きるということは残酷な行為なんです
罪を犯さず もう生きていられるはずがないんです
存在そのものがやっぱりもう弱肉強食なんですよ
いつでも強者がもう弱者を食っちゃうんですね
まあそれ嫌だったらミミズでもなることですね
もう枯れ葉枯れ葉しか食べませんからね
でもミミズになってありがたいわけじゃないでしょうにね
その上に行くと 誰かが誰かを食べてるんですよ
菜食主義だからといってね
私はセンシティブな人間やと
まあちょっと言いにくいでしょう
別にこちらに食いまくるために
もう野菜が現れてるわけじゃないでしょうに
まあ強いて言えば もう野菜はそれをよく知ってるんだからね
もうどう頑張っても食べられるんだと
だからそこら辺でなんとかもう我々の生き延びるためにいろいろ手段を取らなくちゃいけないんだということで手段は取っているんだから
まあ完全に破滅になるということはないんですね
で まあ米なんかはね 今どう？すごい贅沢でしょう
自然には栽培でき もう生えません
あの連中は贅沢になっちゃって面倒見てあげないと
もう雑草やら勝手に すごい元気でしょ
元気でもただ時期もうもう春になってくるとものすごい強烈な勢いでもう
それにしたら もみなんかはもう一生懸命面倒見ないと大きくならないんですよ
ちゃんと水をあげて ちゃんと肥料をあげて
ちゃんと雑草を取ってあげて
でないとえらい贅沢ですよ
もうもう植物なのに 人間が触っちゃうと何でもそうなっちゃいますよ
だらしない もう猫飼ったことと同じですからね
もう猫は猫でなくなっちゃうでしょうに
どうしてもだらしない性格になっちゃうしね
それでもまあ考えてみれば
もうこちらでの行為で
もうもう稲も助かっているし
稲で我々ももう助かっているんですね
そういうことで 稲もやっぱりいっぱい作ってくれるんですね
自分にとってはそんなにいらん
全部稲になっちゃうと
籾はね もうとんでもないことになりますからね
だからまあまあ一応先生も野菜を食べるところでは
まあいくらか向こう側もそれなりに考えて
いろいろ 例えばリンゴはもうものすごく美味しくできちゃって
あれはリンゴの木に入らん
リンゴはもう種だけを考えていて
種周りにいっぱい実をもう進んでおくでしょ
それは明らかに誰か食べてくれということだからね
誰でもみんなが食べてくれると
そうするとその木は考えてね
真ん中の方は麻酔しているんです
誰も食べない ここからここまで食べてよと
ここは捨てろと 捨ててほしいんですね
でも動物はそうじゃないんですね
動物はそうではないんですけど
動物の世界でもやっぱりそこを自然
野菜食べる生き物っていうのは大量に食べる
肉食べる生き物っていうのはほんの少々しか食べないということになっていて
1匹を倒しちゃうと何匹食べちゃうというね
で 鹿 1匹ライオンが倒しちゃうと
もうライオンはみんな食べる
それでできるだけ動物ならもうできるだけ節食
節食じゃない 何でしたっけね
節約 ギリギリの節約で生きている
それで比べたら 全ての自然紛争を破壊しているのは人間なんですね
で クジラとウナギもトントンにで食べる
クジラはいるだけでも美しいんですけどね
これが戦争までするんだからね
とんたんで食べたってのももう
だからまあだから私が何が言いたいかというと
我々はやっぱり生きることによってかなり残酷な行為をやってますよ
野菜にしたって生きてるんだからね
もみも生きてるんだからね
我々食べる大豆 豆なんかがね
水に入れて 1 日置いておけば芽が出るでしょうに
だからじりじりと命なんですよ
それで生命にはもう石は食べられない
砂は食べられない 土は食べられない
命でなければ食べられないんですよ
いわゆる命がある場合では
命があった抜け殻でないと栄養にならないんですね
抜け殻でいいんですけどね
で これで日本になってくる
それでダメ 生で食べないと
生きたまんまで その方がすごい贅沢だと
動物でしょうかね 鳥とかはそのまま生きたまんまで飲み込みますけどね
ああやって生きたまんまで食べるでしょ？いろいろ魚とかね
あれは文化じゃないと思いますけど
あれはまあ蛇ならね 鳥ならいくらかまあ我慢できますけどね
だから抜け殻でね 干し魚でも死んだ魚でもね
もうこう 抜け殻では栄養取れますよ
とにかくどちらかしたっても
かつての命がなかったならば栄養にならないんですね
そうすると生命っていうのは
食欲っていうのは唯一のすごい衝動で
死にたくないっていうことはもう刷り込まれてるんだから
とにかく食う 食わなきゃ食われるというシステムですね
命は だから第一は何なのかと
生命に対する質問の中で
お釈迦様はこれをもう食べ物であると
生命に質問すれば 一は何なのかというと
正しい答えは食べ物と答えなくちゃいけないんです
皆様に一は何ですか？というと
変なことを言うでしょう
頭が悪いんだからね もうこれはもうブッダの世界の智慧がある人だったら
一っていうのは食べるものであると言うんです
これは全生命には一なんです
他 他のは別 後なんです
だから この厳密な論理で考えれば
一日生きるということは恐ろしいことで
かなり生命に迷惑なんですね
他の生命 生きていきたくている他の生命に
はい それは論理は論理なんですけど
実際はそれ避けられますかと
理論は理論ですよ ぴったし
では実際では残酷な生き方をやめられる方法はあるのかというと
その方法もないんです
例えば 人間は野菜よりは肉
魚の方の好きになってるでしょうに
で 昔のも野菜ばっかし食べていることになってくると
一日中食べること時間なくなっちゃうんですよ
今はそんなに時間かかりませんだけどね
もう野菜を作って 米を作って
それからその籾殻を取って
もう大変な作業なんですよ
あのトウモロコシ なんとかの
あの 米で作ってご飯食べてるアピールでしょうに
一日作業でしょ？女性たちが
早くからもう石臼でね
もう米粉にして して またそれはまた平らにして
練って また焼いて 瞬時に食べちゃう
食べるのは一瞬で食べちゃいますけど
あの 薄い細いあのせんべいみたいなパンを作るためには
そのおばさんたちが一日殺しているんですよ
そうすると他のことをする暇って何もなくなっちゃうんですね
食うだけの人生になっちゃいますよ
もう野菜ばっかし食べていると
我々は簡単に手に入れるんだからと言ったっても
やっぱりそれでも買っただけなんですけど
もう向こうはすごい一日一生かけて作っているでしょうに
だから野菜作っている人々には他何もできない
だからそういうちょっとしたハンディがある
時間なくなる 肉の場合は誰かが物を取って焼いて食べれば
もうすぐもう何も 調理もすごい時間残っちゃう
また大量に食べなくてもいいんですね
時間残っちゃうので その生命の一生ですけどね
そこで殺されちゃう そこで終わっちゃいますからね
残酷ですね だからどうすればいいかと答えがないんですよ
肉を食べちゃって 時間
余った時間で大事なことをするのかというと
でも食べられる生命っていうのはかわいそうでかわいそうで
では親切に野菜食べていこうかなと言っちゃうと
一日中食べることに他の暇がないんですね
これまた惨めなんですね
食べるだけの人生だから
どう見たってももう答えがないんですよ
罪を犯さず 清らかに生きてみるぞと思ったら
これはありえない 無理なんです
そこは菜食の人々はいい加減ごまかし
まやかし インチキしないでわかってほしいんです
冗談じゃないんだと この生まれてきてとんでもない罠にはめられたんだと
あなたは それから毎日大量に罪を犯さなくちゃいけないんだと
生きるために だったら早く死ねばいいでしょうと
早く死んだら別なところに生まれ変わるんだから
結局同じです そうすると時間で計算してみると
まあ年人間でいうと年罪を犯しちゃいますから
では私は十歳で自殺して死ぬそうと
自殺してもまた別なところに生まれるでしょうに
要するに時間を儲かったわけじゃないんですよ
そこで同じことをやらなくちゃいけないんだから
それに気づいちゃって
またもう じゃあそちらでもう早く自殺するって
同じこと意味がないんです
だからこの輪廻っていうのは
これ悪魔の仕業であって
神様イコール仏教は悪魔なんですよ
キリスト教の宗教的な神という概念があるけど
何とか何とか創造したというね
森羅万象の創造したという
それは単なる妄想概念ですけど
そこがもう悪魔なんですね
彼らが悪魔という単語を使うのは
悪魔といえばもうもうもう力がないというふうに思ってるんだからね
だから神にしてもどうでもいいんですけどね
神にも力がないんだから
何にもできないんだからね
神神と言ったって だから世界は悪魔に支配されていると堂々と言ってるでしょうしね
だったらせいぜい悪魔やと言っちゃえば楽なのにね
だから輪廻そのものっていうのは本当に悪なんですね
ひと欠片もいいところないんです
まあ天界に行ったら 天界の高いところに行ったら
まあ他の生命に迷惑をかけないでいることはできます
食べますよ 食べるんだけど
まあ他の DNA食べるっていうことはないんですね
まあ神 それも霊的な存在だからね
でも低次元になってくるとまた違うんです
他の生命を依存しちゃうんです
我々も知らないんだけど
誰かに食べられてる可能性ありますよ
私たちのエネルギーやらなんだかんだも
低次元の生命に まあ霊の
で 高次元になってくると
天界ではまあ自分の力で栄養は取る
梵天に生まれたらもうものすごいもう楽で
もう全く禅定の心のエネルギーで生き続ける
その場合は罪がない世界なんですが
問題っていうのはこれ長生きできないんですよ
こちらで修行して徳を積んで天界に行くか梵天に行くでしょ
そこでその徳のチケット終わっちゃうと
どこかに生まれ変わらなくちゃいけないんですね
だからどこも永遠じゃないんだからね
どこに生まれても寿命というものはあるんですよ
生まれた瞬間で もう だからもう神になったらもうもう 100万年いるとかね
1,000万年寿命あると言ったっても
でも寿命が寿命なんですね
梵天になったら光年単位で言いますけどもね
光年というのは宇宙の時間 1個ですから
それの 100  400ぐらいいるとかなり長いでしょ
でもその自分の寿命終わったら
もう別のところに生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
それでまた必ずしもまた修行に修行するということを分からないしね
またどんどんどんどん普通のここら辺にまた戻ってくることになる
だから輪廻はどこにいたっても
これはもう罠ですと それがいくらかでも理解してほしい
それでお釈迦様がここはもうでは作れないのかと
完全もうほぼ完全な罪を犯さない組織を
お釈迦様もいろいろ余計なことを考えるんだからね
では これは輪廻はもう明らかに悪
悪 ブラック 灰色じゃないんです
では この中でちょっとした特別のシェルターという言葉がありますね
原子爆弾が起きてもシェルターの中に隠れていれば大丈夫というね
それでもまあ 半年とかね
それであまりアメリカ大統領だけは何年もいられるぐらいシェルターあるんですけど
あのバカだけ生き過ぎちゃってもね
他の人類人間死んじゃってね
何の意味もないんですけどね
原子爆弾落ちたら我々みんなね
もう世界を維持管理しているみんな死んじゃうでしょうね
原子爆弾落とす連中だけ自分がシェルターに隠れて守られると
それは一般人が作った食べ物を食べて
すごい公平ですね で いくらかね
これ人間にサンプル見せた方がいいんだからね
それを理解するんだからね
この出家制度っていうのは
そういうシェルター的なサンプルなんですよ
でも あまり脆いんですね
だから在家の人々がなければ成り立たないんです
在家の仏教の仏教を信仰している人々がいないと成り立たないんです
だから その人々に支えられて
この罪を犯さないような生き方できるというね
組織を作って それだったらもうただの規制的な生き方ではないかということになりますから
それは規制的にならないように
そういう組織があるんだから
一般の在家の方々にはもう想像を絶する徳が入るようになって
ですからお互いに支え合った方が互いに得するんだよと
いうことで 出家システムできてますよ
だから仏教の世界っていうのはかなり難しいんですよ
理解するのは キリスト教
イスラム教とは大違い
桁違いです 何から何まで微妙な論理姿勢でできてるもんなんです
一つ一つ だから大学の人たちも仏教学ってたった一つじゃないんだから
その中で微妙にいろんな分野に分けて研究してますよ
人数は少ないんだからね
まあ少ないからといって
一人一人がその仏教の世界でもある一つだけ選んで
そこは徹底的に専門的に研究するんだから
もうかなりやります 出家制度っていうのは
この生きているものはどうしても罪を犯すような羽目になっている
そういうシステムです
罪を犯すっていうのは避けられないんだけど
だったら大量に徳を積んだ方が
もう引き算で もう黒字になります
だから赤字だけ 人生は大失敗
すごい黒字の人生だったらOK
でも黒字といってもやっぱりいろいろなくなる
赤字も出る 出るんだけど
赤字の数が少ない だから在家の生き方はもう罪はどうしても罪は犯しますけど
その２ ３個罪を犯すと
もう 100個ぐらいは善行為をしていると
まああれでもうこれも引いてみれば
もう赤字ではなくて黒字になると
いうふうなシステムで
在家信者さんには黒字になる生き方はできる
それがこの出家組織を支えるということです
それで寄付することはなんで得になるのかというと
確実に寄付しなくちゃいけないということになると
もういいんです 例えば元気な人がいる
そいつはもう何も食べてない
夜中が空いている それとあんた
お腹が空いているので
何かご飯でも差し上げましょうか？という気分になるでしょうね
当たり前 お腹が空いていると
でも必ずしもその人にご飯をあげなくちゃいけないという理由はないんです
自分の命だから いわゆる自分の責任を自分で負ったらどうですかね
怠けちゃっていい加減なことゲームばっかりやりやがっちゃって
もうご飯も食べ損なったと
だから大人からやっぱりかわいそうと思ってご飯はあげますけど
だからといって必ずしもあげなくちゃいけないとは言わないんです
逆に赤ちゃんが泣いている
お腹が空いちゃって この乳もミルクをあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
あんた勝手に生まれたんだからね
なんで泣くの？俺は知りませんよ
こんな話にならんでしょ
それは話にならない それはもう育てる義務
当然必然的にある それは自分の子供じゃないとそんな言い訳にならない
それ面白いことを必ずやらなくちゃいけないことをやっていると
えらい気分がいいんですよ
全然損した気分にならないんですよ
例えば動物の子供でも
もう捨てられちゃって
生きることができなくなっちゃって
助けてあげようと思い
助けちゃうと損しちゃった
この子にももう餌食べてもう 800円もかかった
どうしよう 全然その気分がないんですよ
元気になってくると もう楽しくて楽しくて
よかったよかったと だから必ずしもやらなくちゃいけないこと
義務を果たしちゃうと
すぐ返しが来るんです
ものすごい精神的な穏やかさ
それっていうのは一番幸福なんですよ
金が幸福じゃないんですよ
穏やかさが幸福なんです
だから人の赤ちゃんなんですけど
もう泣いちゃってると
自分がミルクを作って
持ったところで赤ちゃんがすごく楽しくなって
グーグーとまた寝たところでえらい気分がいいんですよ
だから お釈迦様がこの完全に心を清らかにした人には
もうあげることは当たり前
当然になっているんだ
なぜかというと 完全に心が清らかだから
他人のものは取らないんですよ
リンゴの木があってもリンゴを取って食べないんです
これはリンゴの木のものである
私のものではありません
それで最後の信者が来て
お坊さんリンゴを一つお布施しますと自分が取ってあげると
あげなくちゃいけないんです
それで幸福でありますと言わなくても
本人がやるべき義務を果たしちゃったんだから
それは極端な その人はもう赤ちゃんとも違って
極端にもう罪のない心ですからね
で 大可になるんだと まあそれはもう阿羅漢のもう悟った方々のケースになってくるとそうなりますけどね
えーまあ だから出家の生活っていうのは
この なんで米もらってはいけないのかというと
米はもうまだ生きている
大根もらってはいけない
大根もまだ生きている
それを食べない 大根をもう煮物にしたら
もう生きているものじゃないんですね
その場合は食べた方がいい
でないと捨てることになる
そういうことで この作った料理しかということになるわけですね
そうすると出家だけは輪廻の中にいながら罪を犯さない生き方ができるんですよ
だからそこはサンプルで見なさいと
在家の人々も 正しい形での本当はそういう生き方やと
しかし余計を考えるとね
みんなにできないでしょうね
だから輪廻は悪いと分かっているのかと
そういうことで もうそれなりに修行するためにはみんななるんです
在家であろうが出家であろうが
修行してもう悟られることになるんです
悟りの道は別に出家だけということではなくてね
在家は結構忙しくて大変かもしれませんだけど
それでも在家でも出家できない人もいろいろ条件でいますから
そこら辺はすごい柔軟性があって
これ智慧の勝負ですからね
たとえ田んぼの仕事で時間が全部なくなっても
智慧の開発というのは邪魔になりませんよということで
悟りの道はみんなに開放されてはいる
別に開放されているという言い方は大げさですけど
方法は教えている これはもう誰にでも実践できるということ
だからこの出家はなんで托鉢するのかというと
この ただ単に あの 生きること自体が恐ろしいんだよということは
あの ちょっとモデルでみんなに見せてあげたいんですね
俗世間はえらくそこら辺は誤解しているし
今の出家もとんでもない誤解はしていますけどね
お坊さんというのは楽やと
ただでもうご飯ばっかし食ってるんではないかとかね
そう楽でもないんですけどね
ブッダの教えをやっているならばね
それはもう最低最悪の気持ち
気分にもなるしね すごい苦労する羽目にもなるし
楽ってことではないんですけど
以上 論理的なところはもうそこだけ
例えば だから我々は罪のない人生にしようと思っちゃえば
これはありえない 不可能なんですね
だったら乞食やるしかないんですよ
乞食やっちゃうと もう人がもう作ったものを食べてるんだから
もう命がないものでしょ？たとえ魚でしたっても
もうとっくに命がないんだから
では乞食人生ってどういうことかと
これまた嫌でしょうね
そうなっちゃうと乞食ではなく
物を受けても お供え お布施をね
受けられる資格を取らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうね
これまた大変なんです
清らかな心を作らなくちゃいけないんです
だからどちらでも楽っていうことではありませんだけど
一応輪廻っていうのはすごい酷いもんだなと
生まれてありがたい めでたいというわけじゃないんだと
生まれることも死ぬことも
どちらでも全くはめでたくのない
結婚式も同じなんですよ
何一つもめでたくはないんです
だからめでたいというのはブッダの生まれだけ
スコーブッダハナモッパード
はっきりそれだけ言ってます
生まれてめでたいといえば
たったブッダが生まれたことだけめでたいんだよ
これであなた方は解放されますよ
うん まあそれで話を終了します
この番目は まあそういう托鉢についてちょこっとお釈迦様おっしゃった
でもちょっと微妙な一言葉で
このミツバチが 花から花蜜を採るようにという
花は全然損しない 花が自分が生まれた目的に達するんです
それで それで世の中で仏教のかぶりをかぶって
あらゆる社会迷惑かけたりするでしょう
あれお布施これに寄付あれやとかね
それはブッダの世界じゃないんです
あまり日本の社会に迷惑かけてない日本のお坊様方も托鉢するでしょ
永平寺に托鉢するし いろんな天台宗でもそれなりに托鉢するし
その人も人に迷惑かけてないんでしょうに
それを自分の修行の一環として
ちょこちょこっと托鉢に出ていて
それでも私がちょっとケチつけちゃうでしょうね
あれは微妙にも日本の社会には迷惑かけてない
日本人もそれで自分たちの伝統的な文化だから
それに触れて心清らかになって結構いいことあるんですよ
永平寺のお坊さんの托鉢でも
他の宗派のお坊さんたちも
でも修行に入ったら托鉢みたいなことはやってはいる
それは立派なことなんですけど
それでもなんであのすす持っていくのかとかね
なんでニャーニャーニャーニャーと色々音を上げたりしているのかとかね
ちょっと品がないでしょ
そんなことやると 私はちょっとまあただ理屈でね
理屈だけない まあこれは日本では避けられないかもしれませんだけど
なのに 世間にあるこの人を搾取する行為っていうのは
仏教と何の関係もないんですよ
本当にブッダの教えから見れば
永平寺の托鉢に文句がなくちゃいけないなのにね
それは誰も文句言ってないです
別に誰に迷惑をかけたことはないんだから
永平寺の維持管理にすごい経済的な負担がかかって変じゃないんです
それは仏教の世界はうまくいってます
どこにも問題なく  それでもなんかブッダの言葉から言えば
もうちょこっとちょっと品がないんじゃないかと言われるブッダの世界だから
この恐ろしく人の財産を奪ったり
奪ったりして どうせやら何やとか言ったり
そんなのはもう仏教と何の関係もないんですよ
で 決まりはミツバチのごとくなんです
お互い様得していないとダメなんです
はい